1 et samson luc ferrandez bonsoir or on
a parlé ensemble le dit ou et finalement
on va le voir il a été parce que la
pression s'accentuait monsieur coderre a
été obligé de donner ce qu'ils voulaient
pas donner tout de suite c'est à dire
ses clients comme consultant cogir qui
était la presse ce matin qui nous
apprenait ce à un groupe immobilier
important eurostar on le savait f.fillon
le savez pas mal général juif clients et
il reste un client confidentielles et il
y en a d'autres aussi la liste est
longue parc oméga ça c'est en outaouais
string way cas des gros projets groupe
et le studio félix et paul qui ont entre
autres ont filmé dans le navette
spatiale alors est-ce que c'était
inévitable 15 a commencé dimanche le
qu'est ce que c'est inévitable qu'ils
allaient devoir le faire avant ce
dimanche le vote oui c'est surprenant
qu'il l'ait pas fait avant parce que
c'est le supplice de la goutte d'eau le
step et comme la formule electric cède à
une analogie que je fais là c'est pas le
même problème mais à chaque jour est ce
que vous allez est ce que vous allez
révélé est-ce que vous avez les pluies
attendues et finalement la dernière
semaine électorale il le révèle il
s'était très mauvais pour lui je
comprends pas qu'il l'ait pas fait
d'abord et puis ou alors il aurait dû
évacuer la question dès le départ hands
ah oui j'ai eu des contrats c'est telle
somme j'ai payé mes impôts voici il
était peut-être pas obligé de c'est lui
qui le dit j'ai plusieurs clients puis
j'en parlerai pas accès terreur c'est
lui qui a amorcé cette roule il y aurait
peut être pu l'éviter c'est pas certain
animation est ce que c'est parce que
entre autres le groupe cogir un groupe
immobilier ils voulaient pas qu'on
laisse aussi aux promoteurs mobilisent
c'est quoi la motivation de ne pas les
donner
sayah je suis qu'il sait moi je pense
qu'en tout cas cette semaine j'ai revécu
la semaine la marque mode comme en 2017
avec la formule électrique ça a été la
même chose dans la dernière semaine tous
ses jouets donner ces tentes étaient
encore une fois à ne pas vouloir le
faire celui qui voulait décider le
moment et ces quatre jours d'entêtement
la lui ont certainement nui dans le
reste de la campagne parce qu est-ce qui
ont sorti aujourd'hui le mans la
première action c'est tout ça pour ça on
a la liste des gens parce qu'elle a le
droit le gardien oui encore une fois il
n'y a pas de relation avec auquel et des
zones troublées ya le droit il était
vers citoyens privés il y aurait à faire
de l'argent il y avait le droit de le
faire le les gens vont dire oui mais
l'eau un an peut-être un rapport avec
l'autre mais dans sa vie privée il y
avait le droit moi ce que je vois là
dedans on parle beaucoup de koji requis
et industrie des mutations
moi là dedans ce que je vois ce qui est
elle est peut-être ça pourrait aider à
les chercher de l'information sur le
mode de construction les tendances en
construction comment ça se passe parce
qu'à la ville quand il y aura des
contrôles ça va se faire en public ça va
ça par les services d'urbanisme ça va se
faire par les projets mais à tout le
moins il va savoir de quoi il parle oui
mais a nié si tu perds mais il est quand
même dans la plateforme de monsieur
coderre des éléments qui font que ça
pourrait favoriser un des groupes
immobiliers et s'il est proche d'un
groupe immobilier en particulier on peut
poser des questions par exemple le 40
millions pour faire du transfert de
zonage bureau à du zonage résidentiel au
centre-ville ensuite la construction de
cinquante mille logements en cédant des
terrains de la ville 50 mille logements
ça veut dire que tout va très vite sur
les permis des réglementations et sur
des conceptions etc se sont ensuite la
réduction du 20-20-20 c'est-à-dire 20%
de la tranche sociale or abordable et
familiale à 15 15 est-ce qu'on peut il
est légitime de se poser la question est
ce qu'il est trop près du groupe
immobilier pour laquelle il a travaillé
pour ne pas prendre en considération
leurs intérêts on n'a pas prendre ce
c'est clair mais il faut parler aussi de
l'autre côté valérie plan d'un veut
avoir soixante mille logements le même
principe 20-20-20 il va vouloir céder
des logements des terrains municipaux à
des promoteurs immobiliers donc les
principes sont les mains moi
l'avantagent puis je le défends pas le
loin de là davantage que je vois c'est
que lorsqu'on va parler de projets
d'habitation on va savoir de quoi on
parle parce qu'on peut on a beau
dessiner des beaux plans son papier mais
sont pas pas ce qu'ils font sur le
terrain des fois on peut passer
complètement à côté il ya des choses qui
sont faisables et des choses qui sont
pas fait d'erreur pourquoi ne l'at il
pas fait tout simplement parce que
c'était une tradition il le savait que
ça s'en venait là les médias demandent
ça chaque 4 a su bien tradition
américaine qui est arrivé ici depuis un
bon bout tu as
pourquoi la paf avant cela je suis qui
doit encore avoir il ya perdu en tout
cas ya perdu des plumes avec ça c'est
clair est ce que l'udc sera l'impact on
n'est pas qu'un portant sur les
électeurs vous pensez moi je pense que
oui parce que ce qui lui était reproché
pendant des années c'est la proximité
une proximité non institutionnelle n'est
pas extraordinaire avec des gens
d'affaires pour faire passer des projets
je lui faisais souvent évoquée evenko il
était proche de développement dont les a
vus souvent ensemble et sait on sur la
question qu'on se pose tout le temps c
est ce que bref mener à ce que co
giresse que fifa passe par les voies
officielles pour le contacter est ce que
le lobby est enregistrée ou est-ce qu'il
l'appelle et lui le souvent ses ventes
il s'est vanté du fait que quand la
fille forme appelle tout cas moi
j'appelle la fifa me répondent pourquoi
parce que c'est denis mais ça cette
proximité là ça fait peur aux citoyens
ait même ça fait peur aux citoyens
ordinaires aux critiques de la situation
vous vous dites à lille ça peut être
parfois un avantage ça peut être un
avantage mais est encore une fois à
l'autre parce qu'ils étaient les uns
pendant la campagne sais pas qui tu es
qui est important ce qui tu connais que
ça aussi ça c'est un autre doute losc
c'est pas bien c'est pas noir que les
latuquois ça me perturbe un petit peu
dont ce qui
perturbe beaucoup de monde c'est le fait
que le grand patron à montréal on en a
parlé aussi michael rousseau grand
patron d'air canada une société qui est
assujettie aux à la loi sur les langues
officielles dans ce pays que michael
russo ne veuille pas parler français il
a il est allé aujourd'hui on a vu des
images il a il a parlé lui qu est ce qu
il sait dans quoi il habille les pires
mais peut-être pas parce qu'il vit en
anglais au quotidien avec des
investisseurs qui viennent du monde
entier déjà du conseil nous traçons qui
vient du monde entier peut-être qu'il ne
sais pas mais c'est une forme de mépris
c'est une forme de mépris parce que ce
que ça nous dit de sexo golok betty 6 à
14 ans c'est pas juste qu'ils parlent
pas en français à ses employés
puis d'ailleurs quand on a un président
et france est anglophone de tout le
monde doit parler en anglais le rapport
du vice président ressources humaines il
est en anglais les données qui sont
fournis les deux rapports de partout de
tout le monde sont en anglais mais ça
nous dit aussi que ce gars là il va pas
dans la société francophone il est pas
intégrée du tout il va au théâtre en
français il fréquente pas des
francophones parce que si on va au
mexique un mois puis qu'on fréquente on
va faire un film dont le tournage on
fréquente un peu des gens on a envie de
communiquer avec eux s'ils lui cette
envie le lieu pas venu en 14 ans ça veut
dire quelque chose annie a et d'entendre
de stan de kwacha non mais sérieusement
l'offre c'est un pas de danse à lille et
à montréal il le même district 14 ans
qui existe depuis 2006 à pied capable de
circuler sans problème qui est tellement
occupé que pas le temps d'apprendre la
langue il répond le commencer par un bon
jour je m'excuse parcours français il ya
commencé pour être honnête le prg est
exact l'effet ligue a commencé par un
bonjour au dc à la chambre de m'avoir
invité après ça il y aura bravo tout le
discours est en anglais puis après dans
le dans l'âme elle est presque dit j'ai
pas le temps d'apprendre le français
j'ai d'autres choses à faire c'est
désolant c'est pas de questions c'est
pas une question de talent un gâteau qui
sont ses interlocuteurs à qui
s'intéressent seydoux sur ses passions
ce gars là il n'est pas intégré la
société montréalaise s'en sort il
parlerait au moins un petit peu très
bien on va se retrouver dimanche soir
vous serez avec moi merci d'ailleurs sur
un plateau michel surgir à d'autres gens
là on vous présentera tout ça pour cette
grande soirée électorale quelques
secondes chacun le cas ni les électeurs
montréalais ont quoi en tête quand ils
vont voter dimanche
il y en a qui ont à la sécurité des
finances y en a qui ont l'aménagement de
le logement le logement et
l'environnement moi je pense que tout le
monde a un peu le logement attac quelle
est la meilleure solution pour le
logement annie les gens premièrement
faut qu'ils aillent voter je pense que
c'est la première chose la première
chose que devrait faire c'est d'aller
voter et sécurité dans leur quartier il
faut qu'ils regardent un peu ce qui les
touche ce qu'il est trop priorité pour
eux qu'il est aussi dans les deux
programmes électoraux j'ai calculé
270 promesse de madame plantes 456 de
monsieur coderre donc il y en a pour
tout le monde mais il faut vraiment que
les gens prennent le temps d'aller
chercher puis de regarder aussi les
candidats dans leur quartier de regarder
est ce qu'on le cas avec qui on veut
travailler avec qui c'est un problème
qu'on va appeler pour ramasser les
poubelles pour le déneigement peau on a
changé nos vies on en reparle dimanche
soir en champions passante panel a
tellement été populaire qu on vous garde
après l'élection le jeune lennon région
va donner les paramètres plus tard merci
beaucoup à bientôt à dimanche soit versé